so obviously sexual abuse has been in
the news quite a bit recently with all
the things going on in Hollywood and
other industries and then the Catholic
Church and now there is you know it
seems like every other week there's
another story this time it's it's Asia
Argento the Italian model an actress who
was one of the original me to Crusaders
and who now stands accused of sexual
assault herself after it was revealed
that she had sex with a 17 year old guy
California is one of the very few places
in North America where the age of
consent is 18 almost everywhere at 17 or
16 and this happened in California so it
it's a crime now and she should face the
legal penalties because the crime is a
crime now let me tell you my concern
this is my concern and I've talked about
this before but I want to go back to him
because I think it's such an important
concept and it's it's it's it's it's an
issue that I just I think we need to
work out this is what I'm worried about
I'm worried that we have turned sexual
assault into such a wide broad category
that it's losing its meaning and in the
process actual cases of rape and assault
are trivialized deprived of significance
because the word is used so often and
and and often to describe things that
really don't qualify I'm very concerned
about this because because of what it
does to the victims of sexual assault
and how it interferes with our ability
to dialogue about these issues and and
also the general confusion that it
causes so I think it's a problem when we
talk about the sexual assault problem
there are it seems like there are many
different types of situations that get
kind of lumped in to it it's one of the
reasons why I don't like the you know me
to once you start putting a slowed one
once you take an issue a really really
serious issue like sexual assault and
you put a slogan on top of it
me too that's the slogan well then it
just it simplifies things way too much
because now you've got you've got this
this slogan this this you know category
and then all these different kinds of
things end up getting thrown into it and
they don't all belong there they don't
all belong with each other right and
it seems like in each industry where
this has where this has been an epidemic
and it's been in the news what you find
really although they all get lumped into
the same category if it if we do have to
put them in categories it seems like
there are broadly speaking really two
different categories so in Hollywood
there are the stories of women being
forcibly raped or threatened or
threatened if they don't go along with
some something and and and there are the
kind of stories you hear about Kevin
Spacey right where he's going around
groping and fondling people against
their will he's forcing himself on
fourteen-year-old kids and so forth you
have situations like with Larry Nasser
where he molested hundreds of kids under
the guise of performing medical
procedures and that kind of thing and
then obviously you have the Catholic
Church and the terrible stories of
children being raped by priests and all
of these stories are provided they're
true of course they are clear-cut cases
of rape and abuse nobody disputes that
ok that's rape abuse assault and the in
all of those situations if there was any
justice in America everybody involved if
they're found guilty they'd all be going
to prison forever even though that has
not that has only happened very rarely
you know in these situations but then
you have this this other category which
gets thrown in and conflated with all
the other ones I just mentioned
so here you have the cases in Hollywood
where actresses willingly have sexual
relationships with powerful men
sometimes for years Asia Argento herself
I believe she was in a sexual
relationship ongoing with Harvey
Weinstein for like five years she kept
going back and engaging in this you know
in this stuff with him and they do this
for the sake of movie roles and so on
and for more you know power and clout in
the industry and then years later after
getting what they want out of it they
claimed that they were being assaulted
the entire time and in the Catholic
Church you have you have some cases
where like cases involving Cardinal
McCarrick you hear about Cardinal
McCarrick and the controversy
surrounding him now there are
accusations that he molested children so
you know that's in that category but it
but that a lot of the accusations you
hear about McCarrick and and also with
other you know some of these other
things as well
these are in some cases he's having sex
with seminarians these are grown men who
he allegedly lured into bed and then had
sex with but
as a grown man if you let another man
lower you into bed
and then you willingly with no
resistance engage in sex acts with him
does that belong in the same category as
the twelve-year-old kids who are raped
by men twice their size I think clearly
it doesn't and then you also have the
accusations against a sergeant or a guy
at 17 legal age almost in all most every
state in the Union willingly has sex
with this you know 100-pound Italian
model making no effort to leave the room
or leave the situation then he comes
back blackmails her demands money for it
and gets paid and now he says he was
traumatized by his willing participation
in sex acts with a woman when he was a
few months away from his 18th birthday
does that belong in the same category as
a woman or a child who gets pinned down
and raped by a sex predator and then you
have cases on college campuses where
we're told now you know drunk sex is
rate is rape that's that's what we're
told now because if you're drunk you
can't consent so drunk sex is
automatically rape so then a woman gets
drunk and this happens all the time on
college campuses I'm sure I'm not
scandalizing you by telling you this but
what happens is people go to parties men
and women and they get drunk and and
many the people they're the reason why
they're doing that is because they want
to have sex with somebody and it's part
of the reason why they go to these
parties so then you have situations
where a woman gets drunk guy gets drunk
they're both drunk they have sex they're
both eager participants in the moment
and then the next day the woman wakes up
and says that she was raped does that
belong you know with these other cases
of rape and then you have instances of
inappropriate language or conversations
in a work environment where a man is
accused of hitting on women or trying to
initiate relationships maybe
unsuccessfully or making rude comments
and all of these also get lumped in and
are stuffed under the kind of me2
umbrella what you have is a wide variety
of cases that in my view are wrongly
even dangerously conflated and mixed
together and compared here's the problem
I think this is where this comes from
this is where the trouble comes we have
as a culture removed all moral
boundaries from sex we have we have
discarded all notions of sexual morality
except for except for consent that is
the one moral rule that we have that we
have maintained when it comes to sex
consent is the only moral rule that we
still observe with sex and so when an
immoral sexual encounter occurs even if
it wasn't rape or assault we have no
language with which to describe it I
think there are many cases where a
sexual or there's some sort of sexual
encounter
and all we all instinctively recognize
that it that it was immoral that there's
something wrong with it
but because we've gotten rid of the
whole idea of sexual morality we just
have no way to describe it we don't know
what to do with it and so we take the
one sexual moral rule that we still have
and we apply it to that situation
because it's all we've got even if it's
even if it's not appropriate in that
case because we have no basis for
condemning any sexual encounter unless
the sexual encounter was non-consensual
so we end up just calling all of these
things non-consensual even if it was
consensual even if both people involved
chose to do this thing in our minds we
have really two categories there are
non-consensual sex which is bad and then
we have consensual sex which we think is
always good that's what we that's what
we've that's what the culture says it's
what we allowed us have most of us it
seems like that's the idea that we have
so as long as they're consenting adults
who choose to do this thing then it must
be okay but the reality is that there's
a lot of bad sex there's a lot of
immoral sex there's a lot of disordered
gross harmful sex that is nonetheless
consensual
all of the cases that I mentioned all
the cases I mentioned they're all
immoral bad gross harmful
but they're not all rape some of them
were
not all of them
and until we acknowledge that there are
other ways to have immoral sexual
relations with a person until we reclaim
sexual morality and sexual boundaries we
will be stuck trying to condemn all bad
sex on the grounds of consent which
expands the idea of consent
so broadly as to render it meaningless
so that when we really need it when
there is actual non-consensual sex
happening it we don't have any
meaningful way to describe it because
the word consent has has become too is
increasingly means nothing because we've
expanded it so much and we've turned it
into this complicated equation where
nobody really knows when consent is
happening and even if a person does
something willingly and it's like yes
let's do this and but even that might
not be consent because we turned consent
into this super confusing a calculus
which it isn't it's actually very simple
now sexual morality is not so simple
that's a much more nuanced thing consent
is simple if you choose to do something
when you could not do it you have
consented that is consent the great
hurdle that we face is this modern idea
that sex is only immoral if it lacks
consent that is false obviously every
situation where sex lacks consent is
immoral that we know
but there are also plenty of situations
where sex is immoral even when it has
consent
so
it is problematic I think for someone to
willingly have sex in a situation where
they could not have sex and then later
say they were raped because that is just
not rape it's not what rape is
um it is problematic for a woman to
let's say have sex with a Hollywood
producer because she wants a film role
and then later after she's gotten what
she wanted out of the transaction say
that he assaulted her it is problematic
and I'm not saying that that's the case
in all of the Hollywood need to cases as
I already said there are plenty of you
know there plenty of cases where there's
actual rape and assault going on but
then there are other cases where it
doesn't appear to be that it's
problematic for anyone to willingly do
something making no effort to refuse or
to get out of the situation and then to
glader a claim that they didn't consent
because willing participation is consent
that is the very definition of consent
the only time that it's not consent the
only time when willing participation is
not consent is when there is something
that precludes the person from being
able to actually willingly consent or
win their consent is coerced so if there
are threats or something involved then
obviously that's not consent that's
that's not willing participation you're
not willing it's it's it is you know
when you're coerced into doing something
that's not willing participation or if
we're talking about someone who is at an
age where they don't possess the mental
capacity to consent or to understand
what sex is and what the ramifications
of it are so obviously that's not
consent either but
as long as the willing participation is
actually willing and the person involved
possesses the mental capacity to make
that sort of willful choice then it was
consensual
yet even if it was consensual
it is not absurd for a person to come
away from a sexual encounter a
consensual encounter feeling violated or
embarrassed or hurt or used it is not
absurd for them to feel like something
wrong happened like the sex was wrong
and like they were wronged in the
process because there is indeed a whole
vast category of consensual yet wrong
sex
and we need to acknowledge that and
start talking about that
rather than trying to make everything
into a salt and rape
now consensual yet wrong sex that
includes a lot of different things this
is a category where you know you have
sex that's transactional sex where it's
not respecting of human dignity where
it's done purely so that both partners
can exploit the other for pleasure or
where one partners exploit the other for
pleasure and the other partner although
they're willingly participating they are
looking for something else out of it or
they think that there's love and
devotion involved but there really isn't
any sex where there's no love where
there's no devotion where there's no
concern for the other person's
personhood okay all of that is bad and
it's gravely immoral but if it falls
into that category where both partners
choose to do it it's not rape it's bad
it's wrong it's even evil
but it's not rape rape is a particular
thing and it has to remain a particular
thing so that we know what it is and
thus can protect against it and can
punish it when it happens and can fully
understand the severity
of
of this terrible evil
which is one of the most evil things a
human being can ever do
I think we have to you know we have to
be willing we have has a as I said we
have to re-establish I think some
boundaries for sex some moral rules
that go beyond just consent and we have
to get away from this idea that just
because it's two consenting adults it
must be okay
that is yo for both people to consent
that is just like square one that's
that's just yeah I mean obviously both
people need to consent clearly
there's more to it than that
and I think it makes it you know when we
have turned consent because we're
because we're trying to make consent
into something that can cover all cases
of immoral sexual relations without ever
actually acknowledging explicitly that
there can be immoral sexual relations
that are consensual so we've you know
when we're broadening consent like this
and or the you know the the idea of
consent when we're turning it into this
very complicated huge thing that's where
you end up with these ridiculous things
on college campuses like affirmative
consent rules where if two people are
having sex they have to continually
throughout the activity they have to
continually verbally say yes I want to
continue doing this yes I want to
continue to and of course that's just
not human human being somehow humans
function that's how robots function
humans are not robots
and so that's absurd but that's what
we've done we've turned consent into
this thing where as I said even you know
when you're a person could be in the
middle of a sexual activity with with
another person and both people could be
willing participants but but that
doesn't mean
that isn't a safeguard against the
possibility that the next day one of the
people involved could say oh actually I
didn't consent yeah I said yes I did it
I was I was into it you know I was will
I never tried to leave I never said no I
never even hinted at No and all that but
actually it was right yeah you know it
was it was actually raped and so it
makes into this really complicated thing
where it's almost impossible we've made
it where it's almost impossible for a
person to actually know if what they're
doing is consensual outside of this
affirmative consent thing unless we're
going that far
where there is verbal affirmative
consent continuously throughout the act
and we become like robots outside of
that it has become almost impossible to
actually know if there's consent so I
think that's where these other moral
ideas and rules come into play
where you could ask yourself yeah the
other person is is a willing participant
but then you could ask yourself is that
do I love this person am i devoted to
them
disrespecting of their dignity am I just
using them for pleasure I mean these are
easier questions to answer these are
easy questions to answer for yourself
you've gotten past the the consensual
part of it yeah they're willing okay now
here are these other questions
and unless we're willing to introduce
those ideas to human sexuality again
obviously over the last several decades
we have ripped all of that away and look
at what's happened as a result until
we're willing to infuse that back into
it to reintroduce those ideas I just
think there's there's no hope of any of
this getting any better all right let's
go do it for me have a great weekend
everybody thanks for watching
Godspeed